bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau ce matin nous vous proposons le
quatrième et dernier débat de notre
série consacrée aux élections régionales
pour la bourgogne et la franche comté
cet horaire inhabituel s'explique par
les multiples changements de programme
due aux attentats de paris qui se sont
déroulés le vendredi 13 novembre dernier
le thème d'aujourd'hui c'est le
développement économique ainsi que la
formation de compétences majeures d'un
conseil régional la région et d'ailleurs
chef de file en matière économique elle
peut impulser des politiques et
entraîner les autres collectivités
dans ce secteur les lire melet bonjour
bonjour quatrième avec nous sur ce
plateau de nice au maire pour la liste
de marie-guite dufay bonjour bonjour
vous êtes premier vice président
socialiste du conseil régional de
franche-comté chargé d'économie vous
êtes par ailleurs maire d'une commune du
pays de montbéliard
marie claude jarrot bonjour bonjour pour
la liste et les rues des ide françois
sauvadet vous êtes conseillère régionale
sortante d'opposition et maire de
montceau les mines en saône et loire à
la meute ailleurs vous représentez la
liste alternative à gauche bonjour
bonjour vous êtes conseiller régional
sortant mrc en franche-comté liste menée
par nathalie vermorel
bonjour pour le front national liste
menée par sophie montel c'est julien
hakkar conseiller municipal d'opposition
à besançon qui est sur notre plateau
bonjour bonjour claire rocher vous êtes
la tête de liste de lutte ouvrière pour
ces élections en bourgogne et en
franche-comté bonjour à vous et pour la
liste modem de christophe grudler
laurent croizier conseiller municipal
d'opposition à besançon est avec nous
bonjour bonjour la bourgogne franche
comté et la région la plus industrielle
de france l'industrie emploie 17 % des
salariés soit 187 milles personnes qui
travaillent pour l'automobile les
transports l'énergie ou le nucléaire
selon les chiffres de l'insee
l'industrie a beaucoup souffert de la
crise de 2008 ce qui explique une hausse
du chômage de 2,7 points ces sept
dernières années mais il reste quand
même en dessous des 10% de moyenne
nationale le taux de chômage est de 9,2
pour cent bourgogne et de 9 4 % en
franche-comté
actuellement on compte deux cent seize
mille demandeurs d'emploi alors nous
allons tout d'abord faire un premier
tour de table
pour voir les points forts et des points
faibles de cette nouvelle grande région
on va commencer par vous de nice au
maire donc comme le disait lilian tout à
l'heure vous êtes vice président
socialiste du conseil régional de
franche-comté chargé des questions
économiques
alors selon vous quels sont les atouts
et faiblesses de notre nouvelle grande
région tout d'abord juste un petit mot
ont fait ce débat le raid deux jours
après l'hommage qui a été l'hommage
national qui a été rendu aux victimes
des attentats
qu'on prépare pense par respect aussi
par pour toutes les victimes
je pense que ça j'espère en tout cas
qu'on aura un débat sérieux et
argumentés et j'espère merci sur la la
grande région monnaie vous l'avez
rappelé une grande région industrielle
25 % des richesses qui sont produites
dans le pays
dans notre région viennent de
l'industrie
c'est à la fois un atout considérable
puisqu'un contribuant très fortement à
l'excédent de moi notre grande région
est excédentaire au niveau de sa balance
commerciale
donc nous contribuerons bien évidemment
aux exportations au niveau national mais
en même temps nous sommes aussi
tributaire bien évidemment de ce qui se
passe dans à la fois en europe et dont
et dans le monde
et donc quand l'europe va bien quand le
monde va bien
notre région est tiré par cette activité
européenne ou mondiale quand ça va moins
bien comme c'est le cas depuis 2008 2009
bien évidemment les choses deviennent
beaucoup plus compliqué pour nous ceci
étant nous avons des atouts
considérables en matière de mobilité et
d'énergie de transport de microtechnique
on a dans l'industrie du luxe ses draps
et donc on reste un territoire très
industrielle et je pense qu'il ya un
potentiel de développement très fort
pour les mois et les années qui viennent
marie claude jarrot certes grandes
régions industrielles mais en même temps
somme de 2
petite région et au final une des plus
petites nouvelles régions aussi donc est
ce qui économiquement la nouvelle région
bourgogne franche comté et elle va
pouvoir exister bonjour je souhaiterais
que l'on parle en termes d'atouts et de
contraintes pour moi il y à une
contrainte majeure concernant la région
bourgogne franche comté qui pourra bien
sûr exister notre contrainte majeure
c'est que nous sommes entre trois
grandes régions
trois grandes régions même si nous avons
une une frontière petite frontière avec
ile de france c'est quand même une très
grande région avec un pib et une
démographie très importante pib le
double double de notre région voir un
petit peu plus
l'auvergne rhône-alpes avec un pib aussi
supérieurs à nous alsace
champagne-ardenne aussi et puis et puis
notre bourgogne franche comté qui se
trouve avec le pib le plus bas bon mais
ce n'est pas une fatalité
ça n'est pas une fatalité et nous devons
faire de cette contrainte de cet état
une opportunité
nous avons une autre contre anne qui est
notre démographie hatton et malgré cela
nous sommes une région et c'est là
l'opportunité nous sommes une région
avec une belle image de marque
une belle qualité de vie une région où
il fait bon vivre
donc ça c'est une c'est une première
chose nous avons une image
d'attractivité avec nos vins avec nos
climats de bourgogne avec beaucoup
d'appellations d'origine contrôlée mais
nous ne sommes pas assez forts
d'un point de vue industriel bien que
nous soyons bien que nous soyons
monsieur sommaire l'a dit la première
région industrielle
première région industrielle de france
on va faire tourner la parole si vous
permettez julien a car pour le front
national quel est votre sentiment vous
sur les points forts et les points
faibles de cette nouvelle région mon
sentiment est le suivant
je pense que la principale faiblesse de
la nouvelle région bourgogne franche
comté
ce sont ses élus ses élus de l'ump du
parti socialiste qui depuis trente ans
nous font vivre une totale asphyxie
avaient annoncé que c'est un débat sur
le développement économiser mois
exactement je pense que j'y suis cc
exécutif qu'il soit de droite comme de
gauche qu'ils soient bourguignon comme
franc comtois qu'il soit au niveau
régional comme au niveau local nous
absolument prix ont pas pris en compte
les critères de développement économique
et j'en veux pour preuve par exemple je
prends une collectivité que je connais
bien le grand besançon puisque j'y suis
élu le grand besançon nous avons des
élus ump s qui se tape sur le ventre
parce qu'ils arrivent à créer 500
emplois en cinq ans ce qui fait quand
même 100 emplois par an sur une
agglomération de 180 mille habitants je
trouve ça vraiment léger et je pense que
c'est la principale faiblesse de cette
grande région
si nous n'arrivons pas à changer c est
lui très bien laurent croizier pour le
modem
votre point de vue mon point de vue
monsieur sommers se défausse un peu
facilement de ses responsabilités quand
quant au bilan de marie-guite dufay
aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
la région est en panne
elle ne crée ni richesse ni emploi je
vais donner quelques chiffres
significatifs une croisance une
croissance pardon quasi nulle sur les 25
dernières années
48 mille emplois détruits depuis 2008 ce
qui fait tourner vous bien 550 emplois
perdus chaque mois ce qui fait 550
familles endeuillées par le chômage
chaque mois on a une augmentation de 10
% des défaillances d'entreprises depuis
2008 ce qui est supérieur à la moyenne
nationale et on a un salaire médian en
bourgogne franche comté qui est
inférieur lui à la à la moyenne
nationale donc on a quand même des
chiffres qui donnent qui donnent le
vertige
donc voilà la réalité du bilan de
marie-guite dufay de monsieur patriat
mais je vais généralisée aussi c'est
quelque part des politiques de droite et
de gauche depuis les 30 dernières
et le bilan économique en tout cas
puisque c'est ce qui c'est ce qui nous
convient aujourd'hui c'est zéro
croissance moins d'entreprises moins
d'emplois dans l'industrie c'est moins
d'emplois dans la sphère présentiel
c'était commerce et l'artisanat ses
services et ses moines pouvoir d'achat
donc on est vraiment dans une
économiquement dans une spirale négative
alors heureusement il ya quand même dans
ce coin dans ce ciel grisâtre on va dire
quelques petit coin de ciel bleu sur
lesquels il faut absolument que les
politiques et venir me résultant à
lamotte ailleurs nous sommes rendus au
vu du contexte national des atouts mise
en cause des élus vous quelle est votre
vision de des forces et des faiblesses
et des faiblesses
déjà quand même un rappel sur la
situation donc ses 140 mille chômeurs
actuellement et 350 milles à peu près
ménages qui personnes qui vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté
je crois que tout ça quand même le fruit
de politiques qui ne sont pas le fruit
des politiques régionales qui sont le
fruit des politiques défendues au niveau
européen est appliquée malheureusement
avec zèle par les différents
gouvernements qui se sont succédé et
c'est pour ça qu'on peut pas comment
faire l'impasse du débat sur la
politique nationale et la politique
européenne
ce serait une profonde et une profonde
erreur vous avez évoqué aussi la
question de la fusion en fait des deux
grandes régions
on nous avait présenté en fait cette
fusion comme l'alpha et l'oméga du
développement économique de notre
bourgogne de notre franche comté on
constate que le mariage de deux régions
pauvres ne fait pas une grande région
riche de quelqu'un d'autre
non mais il est ancien président d achat
et de ceux de ce point de vue et de ce
point de vue l'effacement de l'état qui
résultent jean le répète parce qu on
n'insistera jamais assez qui résulte des
directives européennes de tous les ans
au mois de juin il ya des directives
européennes qui s'applique finalement
aux états membres
et ben voilà le résultat aujourd'hui est
patent et nous sommes dans cette
situation les forces quand même 2 de
notre région denis là la râperie a juste
titre nous avons quand même un tissu
industriel puissant à savoir faire quand
même de qualité reconnu mondialement et
ce sont de véritables atouts un autre
atout c'est aussi la situation
géographique de deux choses l'une où ça
nous écrase parce qu'en effet nous
sommes tirés par l'ile-de-france par le
sud de l'europe le nord de l'europe ou
au contraire on utilise ce carrefour
pour développer nos potentialités gérant
chez et bien moi déjà je tiens à dire
que dans cette élection je m'adresse aux
travailleurs à ceux dont vous parlez
justement et qui crée toutes ces
richesses parce que c'est le travail et
c'est les travailleurs qui créent les
richesses dans la société et moi je
m'adresse exclusivement à cela ou bien
aux exploités y compris aux chômeurs
dont vous parliez aussi qu'ils sont que
des travailleurs qui ont été jetés sur
le carreau et je m'adresse à eux
différemment finalement parce que je ne
pense pas que il ya des solutions
locales et que l'on puisse prendre je me
rends bien locale les problèmes
économiques comme s'il était jouable au
niveau de la région
je pense que il faut avoir un peu de
réalisme et que les travailleurs comme
moi les miens ils savent très bien que
ça ne sera pas par le biais des conseils
régionaux que leurs problèmes le chômage
les bas salaires la crise qu'on nous
fait subir vont pouvoir se résoudre et
moi dans ces élections je leur dis de ne
pas se laisser leurrer par ces solutions
qui n'en sont pas et de voter pour leurs
intérêts et pour leur propre camp en
votant pour la liste lutte ouvrière
donc on va parler maintenant du
développement économique proprement dit
juste deux chiffres puisqu'il a été
question de l'exportation tout à l'heure
donc la bourgogne exporte chaque année
pour 1,2 milliard d'euros
la franche comté pour 2,2 milliards
et puis autre chiffre lors d'un sondage
cette semaine 54% des français
interrogés mettent en tête des
compétences régionales qui compte pour
eux le développement économique
justement
donc on va voir maintenant comment un
conseil régional peut aider concrètement
les entreprises toutes les collectivités
locales donnent un coup de pouce voire
davantage aux entreprises en favorisant
leur ampleur tation est également leur
développement nous
envie d'attaquer ces discussions sur les
outils autour d'un mot finalement la
conditionnalité c'est une des lignes de
fracture majeure entre vous sur ces
sujets entre certains d'entre vous quand
la région et d'une entreprise à
s'installer ou à survivre à une
difficulté
doit-il y avoir des conditions quelles
peuvent être ses conditions alain le
tailleur de votre point de vue faut-il
des conditions quand la région donne de
l'argent à une entreprise doit
s'installer et lesquelles c'est une
évidence
bien sûr qu'il faut est une condition
bien sûr que l'argent public doit être
contrôlé de ce point de vue d'ailleurs
on propose qu'il y ait une commission
d'évaluation des aides publiques
tout au long de l'année pour vérifier le
bon usage de l'argent public mais il ya
une graduation dans la conditionnalité
ça peut être simplement créer des
emplois ça pourrait être d'autre chose
alors vous me parlez des conditions une
profonde il revient sur la création
d'emplois sur le territoire ça c'est un
élément important ne s'agit pas de créer
des emplois à l'extérieur du territoire
régional
ensuite il ya aussi les conditions de
travail des salariés
la manière dont le dans les conditions
sociales progrès social continue aussi à
progresser au sein des entreprises
une condition de l'aide publique ça
c'est une nécessité julien car pour le
front national vous quelles sont les
conditions que vous mettriez si vous
étiez à la tête de la région pour aider
financièrement les entreprises alors
déjà je voulais dire que comme mon âge
il faut cesser la politique qui est mise
en place depuis deux mandats par les
socialistes ne serait-ce qu'en
franche-comté mais c'est la même chose
dans la région de monsieur patriat sert
la politique du distributeur automatique
de billets qui consiste en fait à voir
revenir chaque année les mêmes
entreprises demander les mêmes
subventions et qu'on leur donne ça c'est
la première chose que je voulais dire
vous avez concrètes pardon
nous faisons deux distinctions nous
entre les aides d'abord les aides
directes aux entreprises notamment pour
tout ce qui est création et reprise de
l'entreprise
et puis la deuxième le dm deuxième type
dead ce sont les avances remboursables
sur les avances remboursables les
régions nos régions actuellement sont
très en retard il a fallu que le front
national de sophie montel l'opposition
la région franche comté face des pieds
et des mains pour que madame du fai
puissent enfin avoir la lumière et se
dire que c'était une bonne idée et nous
sommes nous nous souhaitons les
généraliser mais pour revenir sur votre
première question effectivement la
conditionnalité des aides nous semble
indispensable et pour nos trois critères
majeurs doit être respectée sous peine
d'avoir des aides qu'ils soient
remboursés au conseil régional
d'abord la délocalisation des emplois
exactement
en cas de délocalisation d'emplois
encore les entreprises devront
rembourser les aides qui leur ont été
accordées deuxième clause les
licenciements
et puis troisième l' embauche ou le
recours aux travailleurs détachés les
travailleurs détachés faut expliquer de
quoi il s'agit c'est donc un employeur
français qui peut faire appel
donc à des travailleurs étrangers d'un
pays européen
enfin dit ses parts dans une entreprise
étrangère qui peut faire donc venir sur
le sol français
des travailleurs de son pays et qui
n'ont pas donc les mêmes conditions de
travail que les travailleurs français de
rémunération surtout voilà maxime
charron la conditionnalité on la trouve
pas dans votre programme
est ce que c'est parce que de votre
point de vue imposer des conditions
c'est prendre le risque d entreprise ne
viennent pas s'installer dans la région
si on a dans notre programme et je pas
trouvé maintenant je vais répondre sur
ce sujet mais je voudrais quand même
dire que autour de ces tables et
répondre monsieur qui représente le
front national que autour de ces tables
il y a que des élus responsables que
disait du responsable et conscient des
enjeux majeurs du regroupement entre la
bourgogne et la franche comté
donc je ne crois pas que quelques
quelques lieux qu'il soit on puisse dire
qu'on est tournée on est responsable de
ce qui se passe et des difficultés
économiques
je crois que faut pas que les débats
s'engagent le
le débat s'engage comme ça alors sur la
conditionnalité la liste à laquelle j'ai
l'honneur d'appartenir prône le
pragmatisme c'est à dire que nous nous
disons qu il faut un moratoire sur les
clauses d'insertion
il y a déjà beaucoup de clauses
d'insertion qui fixent donc des
conditions ou par là aussi je pense tout
à l'heure des appels d'offres donc il
faut il faut un moratoire parce que ceux
dont on s'aperçoit c'est que les
entreprises ont du mal à se retrouver
dans toutes ces clauses pour pour
répondre en fin de compte je demande aux
marchés que les régions écrivent en
matière de formation professionnelle
mais aussi en matière de développement
économique donc moratoire concernant les
clauses d'insertion qui qui représente
la conditionnelle mais par exemple
médiation que les aides ne soient
débloqués que si des cdi sont réellement
créé par rapport à un engagement
souvient de l'exemple d'amazon en saône
et loire
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça ou
est-ce que vous souhaitez pas que ça
apparaisse pour pouvoir être compétitif
par rapport à d'autres régions c'est ça
ma question initiale alors les aides moi
ce terme ne nous convient pas il faut
parler plus tôt d'accompagnement
d'accompagnement et de confiance
confiance c'est comme avec des mamans et
confiance et que l'on ait l'argent qui
n'exclut pas qui n'exclut pas le
contrôle
il y a déjà beaucoup de clauses
d'insertion
concernant la conditionnalité donc je
crois qu'il faut poursuivre dans
l'accompagnement en direction des
entreprises parce que c'est une de nos
missions
l'accompagnement économique est une de
nos missions forte mais avec un contrôle
peut-être plus plus régulier plus sévère
c'est à dire qu' il ne faut pas que l'on
crie victoire quand une entreprise
arrive avec 350 emplois et que derrière
ces emplois repartent bien sûr laurent
croizier est confiant laurent croizier
pour le modem contrôle confiance
contrôles réguliers
une confiance évidemment je crois que le
rôle du conseiller du futur conseil
régional sera de créer un écosystème
favorable aux entreprises et à mettre
trop de conditions à mettre trop de
contraintes
on va faire fuir des entreprises et on
va et on va abaisser la question des
lions tout à l'heure attention trop de
contraintes peuvent faire tomber ces
gens d'après d'autres régimes note de
notre territoire a après il ya des
minimums par exemple nous nous sommes
l'église de christophe grudler nous
sommes contre toutes les subventions qui
seraient des pertes nettes sans
assurance d'un retour sur investissement
sur l'emploi par contre évidemment nous
sommes pour le maintien de tout ce qui
est prêt à taux zéro ce qui est avances
remboursables
parce que pour nous c'est non seulement
éthique et c'est une bonne gestion c'est
une gestion responsable de l'argent
public et je crois qu'il faut aussi
maîtriser c'est que ce n'est pas le
conseil régional qui créent les emplois
c'est les chefs d'entreprise ce et les
entreprises qui créent les emplois et il
faut vraiment créer un lien constructif
entre les entreprises un lien de
confiance et faux que le contrat soit
gagnant gagnant et à partir du moment où
ces conditions sont toutes réunies il ya
aucune raison qu'une entreprise ne crée
pas d'emplois si les contrats de
commande sont remplis
elle créera des rampes d emploi est
clairement chez je déforme votre pensée
si je dis que vous n'êtes pas favorable
aux aides aux entreprises n'ont
absolument pas vous avez bien raison moi
je trouve que ce cette façon de poser le
débat est vraiment une façon
complètement piégé parce que c'est
laisser sous-entendre que c'est les
entreprises qui sont au coeur de
l'économie et qu' il faut les aider
c'est une manière ligne de fracture et
elle est réelle et franche des je suis
seul de mon côté et parce que toute
l'économie
enfin c'est une manière de faire oublier
que ces entreprises ce sont elles qui
actuellement licencié que dès qu'elles
sont un petit peu puissantes elles vont
mettre leur argent dans la spéculation
ou en bourse ou racheter d'autres
entreprises et que dans tous les cas
elles sont maîtresses chez elle et elle
ne crée pas d'emplois en ce moment et on
a besoin
d'autres licenciements l embauche aussi
alors écoutez ça fait 20 ans 30 ans que
l'on nous sert tout les mêmes méthodes
pour leur enlever leur enlever des
impôts les aider les soutenir les
accompagner lors donner un nid douillet
un écosystème favorable j'en passe et
des meilleurs et le chômage ne fait
qu'augmenter
donc il faut à un moment donné à arrêter
de vouloir masquer cette réalité là si
vous voulez toutes les politiques au
contraire d'austérité qu'on subit
actuellement ou même les politiques dead
elle vise à drainer encore plus une
partie de l'argent de la population vers
ses richesses là et donc il ya une
fraction minoritaire dans ce pays qui
s'enrichit toujours plus et la majorité
des gens continuent à s'enfoncer et on
nous explique qu'il faut encore aider le
patronat donc moi je m'adresse aux
travailleurs et je le redis que il faut
que ceux qui sont plus dupes de toutes
ces politiques qui propose finalement au
bout du compte exactement la même chose
à savoir soutenir le patronat petit ou
grand localement et c'est sous prétexte
de créer des emplois alors qu'ils on
supprime
eh bien il faut que ces travailleurs ils
nous arrêtent de voter pour toutes ces
solutions qui n'en sont pas et qui
votent pour leur propre intérieur pour
leur propre la garnir ce tour de table
par denis sommaire donc julien car
disait que la région de franche comté
était je cite un distributeur de billets
vous en dites quoi et conditionnalité
quels sont les moyens de contrôler que
vous avez est ce que vous contrôlez bien
sûr tout d'abord une remarque vous avez
rappelé tout à l'heure où monsieur que
ce sont les entreprises qui créent des
emplois
vous avez parfaitement raison de
rappeler cela ceci étant quand on perd
des emplois ce sont aussi des
entreprises qui en supprime l'inversé
vrai et pourquoi ça se passe ça s'est
passé comme ça au cours de ces dernières
années
quand on regarde ce qu'est ce qu'on
appelle les taux de marge dans les
entreprises
depuis des années 2000 jusqu'en 2012
c'est pas la gauche qui étaient cotées
au pouvoir
les taux de marge les entreprises ont
perdu 10 points on est passé on est
passé en gros de 30 2% à 23 10 points
de perte de compétitivité dans nos
entreprises et il se trouve qu'ils
créent des entreprises qui créent des
emplois dans notre région et partout en
france ce sont les pme et les pmi et
l'artisanat et le commerce
pourquoi nous tirer c'est pourquoi nos
systèmes z il est complètement tournée
en direction des pme d'ici ont besoin de
cours lactalis qui ont rejoint de quoi
qui ont besoin des noms l'investissement
qu'ils ont besoin de fonds propres qui
ont besoin qu'on les aide à recruter des
cadres à l'export etc et on me voit
toutefois le garantis dans fais quoi
maintenant donc l'écosystème dont vous
avez parlé
en réalité il existe aujourd'hui on est
capable d'offrir une solution globale à
une entreprise qui en développement qui
va créer de la richesse et qui créent de
l'emploi
alors comment on contrôle tout ça on le
crée déjà au départ dire qu'une
entreprise qui est dans une logique qui
consisterait à délocaliser massivement
quand je dis délocaliser c'est à dire
des productions s'arrête emprunte pour
être installées à l'extérieur cette
entreprise on va pas l'accompagner une
entreprise qui fait appel à des
travailleurs détachés
vous en connaissez beaucoup des pme pmi
dans l'industrie qui font appel à des
travailleurs détachés vie celle que je
nomme je sais que vous avez non monsieur
la salle est quelque chose à faire mais
on a su le trait aux lascars un conseil
régional de franche-comté non monsieur
ça n'existe pas je crois d entreprise
industrielle eh bien il se trouve que
les entreprises dont vous parlez c'est à
dire les empile des entreprises du
bâtiment et des travaux publics ne
bénéficient pas il est direct de la
collectivité
donc nous avons décidé de mettre c'est
que c'est par cas si c'était un terrible
réaliser bah oui c'est la réalité
celui qui vous a pris par les bonnes
notes à céret mal travaillé c'est moi
même je vois donc on a mis en place on a
mis en place d un système d'avancement
pour ça pourquoi un système d'avancés
pour ça tout simplement parce que ça
nous permet d'intervenir à une hauteur
suffisante parce que ça permet aux
entreprises d'avoir de la trésorerie de
financer tout ce qu'il ya autour de leur
investissement c'est à dire vraiment
d'être dans une logique de croissance
on intervient à un niveau supérieur
quand le faisait avec les subventions et
c'est ce dispositif là il a été mis en
place par marie des buffets c'était un
engagement électoral prend dans la
campagne de 2009
marie-guite dufay et 10 juin
généraliserait
avancement pour ça et pourquoi on l'a
fait et on l'a fait parce qu'on a
discuté avec nous ce qu'on appelle les
corps intermédiaires qui étaient souvent
décrié par le passé par d'autres c'est
les partenaires sociaux en particulier
les organisations syndicales de salariés
et organisations patronales les
consulaires et on s'est mis d'accord sur
ce système des taux l'a pas inventé
concert du hall 3 autour d'une table on
la construit ensemble
alors quand un dossier est présenté on
va vérifier quoi
l'impact environnemental l'impact sur
l'emploi l'impact sur l'avènement de la
formation et si sur les questions comme
celle là il peut y avoir un problème
entre indiciels l'aide inconditionnelle
cancer nci à une intervention d'autres
deux partenaires qui sont là pour aider
à continuer ce tour de table
on va parler maintenant d'une autre aide
non pas financières j'allais dire
matériel quels sont les outils qu'une
région peut mettre en place pour aider
une région on va commencer cet
écosystème beaucoup parlé voilà
l'écosystème dont vous parlais tout à
l'heure on a commencé par vous laurent
croizier quelles sont les aides par
exemple pour une revendication forte des
chefs d'entreprise pour le haut débit
quel est votre projet en matière de haut
débit en franche comté bourgogne alors
sur sur sur le haut débit
tout d'abord je pense qu' il est temps
de comprendre que on est dans une
véritable mutation de notre économie et
que le numérique dont fait partie le
haut débit est un des enjeux majeurs de
l'industrie du futur et c'est sur cette
industrie du futur que la liste l'union
du centre envie de miser tout d'abord il
faut accompagner les départements dans
le fibrage des territoires ça c'est une
des prairies braille ça veut dire la
finance après son installation la vie
pratique donc tu très haut débit ensuite
l'installation de la fibre c'est
construire des routes
maintenant il faut mettre des voitures
sur ces routes entre guillemets donc il
faut travailler avec les entreprises sur
les usages qu'elles vont pouvoir faire
de ce très haut débit donc
nous nous nous voyons le travail sous
trois angles des usages à vocation de
développement économique des usages à
vocation médicale et des usages à
vocation éducative
voilà ensuite on nous pensons que en
bourgogne franche comté sur le domaine
du numérique il y à peu près 34 emplois
sur dix mille ça comme ça représente à
peu près 34 emplois sur dix mille la
moyenne nationale est à 100 emplois sur
dix mille ça veut dire que notre
objectif c'est de ramener au moins à la
moyenne nationale le nombre d'emplois du
numérique sur le territoire
ce qui fait qu'à l'issue du mandat nous
pourrions créer vingt mille emplois je
dis bien 20000 emplois donc c'est
quelque chose qui qui ramené à la
moyenne nationale c'est quelque chose
qui ne peut paraître pas exceptionnel
mais je pense que on a vraiment en
misant sur ce secteur là une potentielle
d'emplois qui est qui est intéressant
marie claude jarrot on sait que les
conseils départementaux sont tous en
train de travailler sur ce sujet du haut
débit
peut-être d'ailleurs avec un peu de
retard par rapport à certaines époques
où beaucoup de choses n'avaient pas été
fait on s'est même qu'un certain nombre
de départements de bourgogne et de
franche-comté six départements sont en
train de monter une société on va dire
pour voilà c'est un petit peu technique
mais qui commerciale et pour essayer de
négocier la circulation on va dire sur
ces ce système qu'elle est de votre
point de vue l'articulation qui peut y
avoir entre le travail des départements
qui vont devoir amener la fibre un petit
peu partout et quel rôle d'un conseil
régional finalement je vois monsieur les
que vous avez bien lu notre programme
puisque nous avons six canons une
émission sur le haut débit a peu de
temps pour tout vous dire puisque
effectivement le françois sauvadet
souhaite doubler doubler l'aide
régionale et s'aligner sur l'aide de
l'état et l'aide des départements
puisque nous travaillons avec déjà six
départements sur vite donc je fais une
parenthèse ces départements sur 8 il y
en a six départements en bourgogne
franche comté qui sont à droite et
françois sauvadet a dit qu'il espérait
que les deux autres départements nous
rejoindrait dans ce beau projet
d'équipement numérique de notre
de notre région ça représentera entre
2015 et 2020 près de 160 millions
d'euros
dead qui permettra de qui permettra
d'équiper notre territoire
ça créera des emplois ça créera des
emplois c'est bien beau de dire on va on
va aider en plus mais il faudra faire un
effort d'investissement et cet effort
d'investissement
il sera il sera compensée par une
diminution du fonctionnement
c'est très important parce que l'argent
est rare donc aide pour le développement
du très haut débit avec investissements
mais efforts sur le fonctionnement mais
je voudrais revenir si vous permettez
madame sur un point sur l'industrie
n'opposons pas vous avez déjà de l'avant
dans le port ne posons pas l'industrie
elle n'opposons pas les grands groupes
et les tpe
pensons aux grands groupes aux tpe qui
sont souvent sous traitantes qui sont
souvent aussi qui ont un potentiel
d'innovation et pensons aussi aux
grandes filières à la le tailleur pour
le haut débit qui elle est là propos les
propositions que fait votre liste
sur le haut débit évidemment il c'est un
véritable enjeu mais je trouve quand
même c'est assez cocasse quand même que
dans une période vous l'avez rappelé
madame de difficultés budgétaires pour
les collectivités qu'on amène cette
proposition comme si elle était
complètement désincarnée de la réalité
faute majorité c'est votre majorité qui
part à l'intermédiaire d'appels à
projets a favorisé les entreprises
privées pour le déploiement du très haut
débit en zones denses et alain vers sa
réserve et a laissé je dirais à la
collectivité publique à nous tous un
rôle à chaque citoyen le financement des
zones peu denses je pense que la
première déjà mesure à faire c'est aussi
de revoir le modèle économique du
déploiement du très haut débit en france
ça c'est une illusion et un os et
régionales a les moyens à le levier pour
faire ça un conseil régional seul n'a
pas les moyens mais évidemment que c'est
un rapport de force qu'il faut faire
quand on fait de la politique on n'est
pas des techniciens on n'est pas des
gestionnaires on est là pour établir un
rapport de force avec le avec l'état
avec l'europe avec les autres
collectivités
c'est ça la réalité fodé élu combatif
ce gauche qui ne sont pas là simplement
pour appliquer ce que des directives qui
peuvent venir d'ici ou de là claire
rocher concernant le haut débit
on peut écouter moi je pense que c'est
enfin une manière encore une fois
d'arroser assez largement quelques
notables locaux et de créer des marchés
et qu'on ne se sont pas des gadgets qui
n'ont comme intérêt que d'amuser la
galerie
je pense vraiment que la population les
travailleurs les miens les exploiter
auquel je m'adresse ne sont absolument
pas concerné par ça et qu'ils ont bien
raison parce que finalement c'est quand
même globalement comme un homme amérique
packaged excusez moi mais le numérique
maintenant c'est dans l'agriculture
c'est dans l'industrie mobile c'est donc
médicale écoutez c'est dans la
distribution
vous faites tous comme si c'était
possible de relancer localement cette
économie comme si régionalement on
pouvait agir sur ces leviers là etc
mais c'est faire oublier que l'économie
elle est en crise dans la région mais
aussi en france et dans le monde et
c'est faire oublier que cette crise on
l'a fait payer à une catégorie de la
population qui est celle des
travailleurs et qui sont les classes
populaires toutes les politiques
d'austérité qui sont prises actuellement
que ce soit au niveau de l'état ou même
au niveau de la région en plus petits
ceux des aspirateurs qui vise à
transférer tout l'argent aux banquiers
au travers de la dette aux entreprises
et la population n'en voit pas la
couleur
si vous voulez un exemple locales ont
parlé des emplois et c'est le principal
employeur privé dans la région
c'est la famille peugeot c'est peugeot
citroën cps la famille peugeot sa
fortune privée l'an dernier est passé de
2 milliards à 3,6 milliards d'euros
je parle même pas de leurs profits je
parle de leur fortune privée et dans le
même temps ils ont licencié près de
quinze mille travailleurs alors si vous
voulez savoir
et bah écoutez le chômage c'est ça c'est
pas chez valeur des jeux termine c'est
pas un effet pervers de la crise et
c'est une politique qui est menée
un choix qui est menée de faire peser la
crise sur les classes populaires et on a
beau un rosé d'argent la bourgeoisie la
bourgeoisie ne jouent pas le jeu
il ne crée pas d'emplois il se lance
dans la
finances y compris ps à ses principes au
profit elle le fait en tant que banques
et donc moi je m'adresse aux miens pour
leur dire qu'il va falloir un moment
donné faire payer les riches et que si
on ne peut pas le faire dans ces
conseils régionaux en tout cas on peut
l'affirmer en votant pour notre liste
julien k on est parti loin du haut débit
mais vous avez tout à fait loisir de le
faire comme vous le souhaitez mais on y
revient avec vous quel est le programme
du front national à ce sujet ce que vous
pensez que c'est lui alors pour cadrer
un peu de choses à penser que c'est une
priorité ce que vous pensez que c'est le
rôle d'un conseil régional d'impulser
peut-être même de mettre de l'argent là
dessus ou pas bien sûr le haut débit est
une priorité je pense particulièrement
aux territoires peu denses
nous en parlions la haute saône par
exemple sur certains secteurs qui ne
sont pas encore accordé notre rôle va
tête de travail et que les conseils
départementaux pour mailler le
territoire et j'aimerais que la région
puisse faire pression également sur
france telecom l'opérateur pour relier à
certains départements entre quand il ya
un pylône qui sépare deux communes d'un
débat fin de deux départements
différents
mais c'est un outil parmi une panoplie
d'outils et il ya un outil qui nous
tient beaucoup à coeur au front national
qui est la commande publique
la commande publique c'est une mission
c'est l'investissement c'est une des
missions du conseil régional est
l'objectif d'une collectivité locale va
être de privilégier l'emploi local aussi
sur cela pardonnez-moi selon quelles
règles parce que alors justement
j'allais venir devant un tribunal
l'emploi local cyclo qui n'existent pas
l'union européenne nous nous a posé
énormément de contraintes dans ces
domaines pour limiter l'emploi local
mais il nous reste quand même quelques
armes notamment autour des clauses
sociales environnementales et de
cohésion territoriale qui sont
activables et que nous traitons activé
que nos actifs ou lorsque nous aurons
gagné la région avec soir benoît sur un
sur un appel d'offres l'emploi local ça
peut pas figurer bien sûr que si on veut
exiger que les gens et grands une clause
par exemple environnementale vous pouvez
privilégier l'entreprise qui travaille
près de chez vous plutôt que les
entreprises portugaises facile
c'est quoi le rapport avec les travail
eric besson
numérique je sais que vous n'écoutez pas
ce que je raconte mais je vais le
refaire comme ça mais je ne me semble
que c'est le haut débit le haut débit et
du débat que consacré justement
embrasser que si on a tout à fait voilà
le bien mais les questionner sur le
numérique c'est parce que je vois pas
tous passionnants tournesol sur les sur
les outils nous sommes monsieur sur les
outils à la disposition du conseil
régional alors peut-être que
effectivement vous ne souhaitez pas que
j'aborde ces sujets puisque ce sont des
sujets que vous ne savez pas vous le
savez la mettre en oeuvre
mais moi je compte le faire et puis
l'inde et deuxième axe sur la commande
publique
c'est le patriotisme alimentaire nous
souhaitons que les lycéens et les
étudiants et les apprentis dans les cfa
puissent manger français et bio dans les
camps plaidé cantine ce qui fera
travailler notre agriculture les clubs
c'est le thème d'un d'un autre de ses
régulières de nice vers le haut débit
j'ai l'impression très logiques
différentes qui ont été menées en
bourgogne et en franche-comté mais qui
manifestent aussi la volonté tout le
monde fait d'avancer sur ce sujet
les deux les deux régions ont consacré
programmé dans leurs programmes
d'investissement de soutien aux
investissements contre en partenariat
avec les départements
je crois que c'est 135 140 millions de
voix 5 voix là bas au total ça fait 130
135 140 millions pour la grande région
auvergne bourgogne franche comté
donc il ya une vraie volonté de
travailler sur le sujet on a consacré
aussi beaucoup d'efforts à travailler
sur la mise en place de la dorsale c'est
à dire la liaison lyon paris strasbourg
lyon parce qu'il faut bien se pencher
quelque part et puis nous travaillons
avec les départements en suisse ou
ailleurs de droite où qu'ils soient de
gauche
nous travaillons avec tous les
départements qui vous choisit pas nos
choisit pas nos partenaires et vous avez
cité d'ailleurs les départements de la
haute saône il ya une politique très
volontariste conduite par yves
krattinger dans ce domaine là si vous
avez cité but vous avez dit tout à
l'heure vous étiez élu à besançon à
besançon c'est une ville qui est
troisième 13 en avant ce réseau lumière
c'était ce que déjà il ya quelques
lumières éditions du seuil
voyez vous voyez le
le niveau d'initiative de cette de cette
ville le data center il est il est quand
même un gros datacenter sur sur besançon
il ya une école du numérique qui vient
d'être voilà donc on a juste eu juste un
mot pour finir on nous dit vous n'êtes
pas d'accord juste un mot c'est on peut
peut-être aller plus vite et la grande
région elle va nous permettre d'aller
chercher notamment des financements
auprès de la banque européenne
d'investissement parce que la banque
européenne d'investissement dont les
discute avec les collectivités à partir
du moment où les programmes
d'investissements vont au delà de 100
millions d'euros
et bien sûr des sujets comme ça on
pourra faire plus vite et plus fort
grâce à la grande région
on va passer maintenant au dossier
formation s'est directement banquiers au
monde économique l'éducation et
l'information sont des compétences
central d'un procès régionales en
bourgogne franche comté quelques
chiffres 54 cfa centre de formation des
apprentis 19000 apprentis 215 lycée qui
accueille 110 mille jeunes et puis
concernant l'enseignement supérieur
soixante quinze mille étudiants dont 45
pour l'université de bourgogne franche
comté
alors comment améliorer l'information
des jeunes comment mettre en et en
équation juste les besoins des
entreprises et ces formations bien on va
commencer par vous que l'accroché mais
quel show je suis déjà frappé par votre
dernière phrase qui est de mettre en
relation les la seconde et c'était juste
ex-époux raison cette question la
formule et capteurs agit pour moi ce que
je tiens à dire par rapport à
l'information c'est que c'est un secteur
effectivement qui est partiellement
financier par les régions et donc sur
lesquels par les impôts locaux notamment
mais malgré tout c'est quelque chose qui
est cadré nationalement dans le cadre de
l'éducation nationale pour beaucoup et
je pense que faire des promesses
localement ses interviews il ya deux
mois faire la carte des formations au
niveau de son territoire
oui bien sûr j'entends ce que je pense
c'est que ce système éducatif il est
actuellement décrié andy qui coûtent
trop cher qu il est trop gros qu'il est
trop rigide que est en fait finalement
ce qu'on reproche souvent à ce système
éducation français c'est la même chose
qu'on reproche aux hôpitaux publics dont
je fais partie c'est d'avoir ce côté
égalitaire et non profitables et ça fait
partie encore des secteurs qui
actuellement sont vampirisé par les
banques
ça a été une véritable politique pour
l'hôpital ces dernières années de nous
mettre sous la coupe de la finance voilà
je pense que l'éducation on reproche
aussi énormément de choses qui sont un
accès égalitaire à l'éducation auquel
moi je tiens et par ailleurs je finis
sur l'apprentissage et la situation
voilà on a qu'on a compris l'essentiel
de votre message
alain le tailleur vous êtes un petit peu
en retard sur votre travail en retard
d'un seul et j'ai pas pu développer tout
ce que je voulais sur le développement
économique mais je vais essayer d'y
revenir on essaie de faire rentrer un
champ de vision à trois écrans et ce qui
est évidemment bien évidemment les les
vendeurs mais les deux sont évidemment
évidemment très lié d'abord sur la
formation
je crois qu'il faut pas opposer la
formation géré les glisser avec la la
compétence qui a été transféré un pour
la gestion des bâtiments et puis pour
diverses que l'autre compétences à la
région
et puis aussi l'enseignement supérieur
alors je voulais le site et on n'aura
sans doute pas le temps de développer
mais pour en termes d'attractivité
justement pour la région bourgogne
franche comté c'est un élément essentiel
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
sur la formation continue
nous nous défendons un grand service
public de la formation et de
l'orientation alors lien pour créer
décident les synergies sur l'ensemble de
la région avec les différents organismes
qui sont qui sont aujourd'hui présents
nous défendre évidemment la formation
des demandeurs d'emploi et pour faire un
lien aussi avec le précédent le
précédent sujet nous le développons
aussi la volonté de bâtir un fonds
régional pour l'emploi et la formation
ça veut dire quoi concrètement son
traitement des jeux vraiment un peu de
concret alors concrètement le que le
fonds régional pour l'emploi de la
formation serait consisterait à
regrouper toutes les sommes en fait
financer y compris les sommes qui sont
utilisés par là par la bpi mais aussi
les aides les aides publiques de
de la région dans un seul faux pour
faciliter aussi l'accès au crédit des
entreprises pour faciliter aussi les
dépenses de formation pour que qui est
vraiment une vision stratégique une
vision cohérente sur l'ensemble de du
sujet je me trompe que vous proposez que
ce fonds soit cogérée par l'air voilà
les employeurs et les salariés qui fait
une nouveauté notamment une gestion
paritaire
ça me paraît une évidence là aussi
d'abord parce que je pense que c'est
important qu'il y ait une convergence
aussi des analystes après une
convergence pendant un partage des
analyses et je serai et je suis à peu
près sûr que sur un certain nombre de
sujets vous pourrez avoir des
convergences
nous nous considérons que la crise
aujourd'hui qui sévit en europe et en
france fait subir les mêmes pressions
sur les salariés sur les fonctionnaires
mais aussi sur un certain nombre de
chefs d'entreprises de pme et de pmi je
pense que vous avez rattrapé votre tank
moral
laurent croizier pour le modem je crois
qu'il est important aujourd'hui de
renouer les liens entre les citoyens les
entreprises et les établissements de
formation que ce soit à lisser ou
instituts de formation et je crois qu'il
est aussi important de redonner un
avenir à nos enfants ici dans la région
bourgogne franche comté selon l'insee en
2012 il y avait 600 mille étudiants
titulaires d'un diplôme universitaire et
la moitié de ces six cent mille travail
et à l'externe en bourgogne franche
comté donc 600000 s'étaient toutes
générations pouvoir d'achat de 600
milles ça fait beaucoup de générations
confondues donc il faut il faut
absolument que ont créé une attractivité
suffisante pour que les personnes qui
sont formés en beaucoup de franche-comté
travail en bourgogne franche comté et on
pense que ça passe par des choix
politiques qui sont forts première
proposition qu'on fait c'est supprimer
le plan lycée de madame du fait qu'ils
tapent sur qui tablaient sur une baisse
d'effectifs et des fermetures de lycée
nous vous voulez en construire des gnons
supprime non mais on veut des contrats
lycée qu'ils soient concertés avec la
communauté éducative et non pas imposer
à la communauté éducative faut
absolument que le politique passe dans
une phase qui soit plus d' écoutes qui
soit plus en phase avec des
réalité du terrain et qui ne se basent
plus sur des a priori et des des
sensations de julien a car pour le front
national quelles sont vos propositions
s'il vous plaît concrètes fond sur le
chapitre de la formation
d'abord je pense qu'il faut qu'on arrête
de voir la formation professionnelle
commune
une façon de sortir les gens des
chiffres du chômage pour nous la
formation doit d'être en adéquation avec
les besoins des entreprises et pas avoir
des formations d'arbitrés basket comme
on a pu le voir lors de la précédente
mandature
il nous faut des commandes et formation
dans les secteurs qui emploient qui
recrutent à savoir le btp à savoir la
restauration à savoir l'agroalimentaire
et l'industrie pour le nord
franche-comté notamment la deuxième
proposition que nous faisons sur la
formation professionnelle c'est la lutte
contre la fraude qui explose en france
et de les saler l'eau si votre road à
quoi depuis la fraude des différents
organismes de formation nous devons être
vigilants là-dessus que vous pensez
qu'il ya pas de contrôle il ya près de
lange en a pas mais tout comme un on a
déjà évoqué le contrôle alors
complètement on a déjà visité en train
de remettre en cause l'honnêteté des
gens qui travaillent dans ce domaine là
vous le fait d'organiser la formation
tout à fait monsieur d'un cynisme je
suis désolé c'est la vérité eric gellé
peut-être ça quand même
est-ce que je peux terminer web toute
légitimité à porter plainte contre
monsieur soulagement je vais me
permettre de continuer mon propos sur
l'apprentissage concrètement
nous voulons revaloriser également les
l'image des métiers de l'apprentissage
qui nous semble complètement obsolète
autant vis-à-vis de diouf du milieu
éducatif parce qu'il ya encore des
lacunes dans ce domaine mais aussi
auprès du grand public qui craint
notamment que le métier parce que on
vous parlait de concret on parle
beaucoup de silver economy avec les
filières que sont la domotique
l'adaptation des transports publics fin
tous ces métiers qui vont permettre d'
accompagnement et d'accompagner le
vieillissement des seniors par exemple
par exemple on allait les métiers des
services à la personne qui sont encore
dévalorise aujourd'hui nous voulons à
tout prix
revaloriser cette image en la mettant
dans le pardon dans le champ de
l'apprentissage tout à fait et je sens
déjà la mise à niveau et je alors si
vous un niveau cinq niveaux à papier
c'est la paix et puis sophie jeanne
dernière mesure finissais mes yeux en
rade
je souhaiterais que l'on réaffecte les
1000 euros qui sont proposés pour les
migrants aux places d'apprentissage
voilà
marie claude jarrot et puis après on
fera tous les bonis sommes à la fois
réagir sur ce qui vient d'être dit et
puis de façon générale sur moi je
voudrais dire à denis halles à monsieur
sommaire une seconde sur le haut débit
c'est que c'est françois françois
sauvadet
vous avez indiquée l'initiative qui est
qui est à l'initiative de cette réunion
des six départements sur le haut débit
est de ce travail pour ramener pour
ramener des fonds pour favoriser
l'équipement haut débit de notre grande
région l'engagement des régions haute et
sociaux demandent si épartement sur 40
millions d'euros vous êtes d'accord avec
moi ça existe oui mais mais
c'est françois sauvadet qui est plongée
la réunion disant conviendrait c'est
françois sauvadet grille a lancé l'appel
aux six départements ce département ça
concerne pas le fibrage ça concerne une
société pour gérer la suite géré
l'aspect unique alors qu'elle fonctionne
cette formation m'a alors formation
apprend que vous avez réseau tous les
deux sur le rôle des départements et
voilà la proximité pas à vos réseaux
avec les la maison d'information alors
sur la formation
bon moi les inventaire à la prévert ça
m'intéresse pas ce qu'il faut c'est
l'action d'abord il faut bien que nos
auditeurs sache que l'information
professionnelle
c'est une grande grands mots qui doit s
est une compétence clé de la région
quand on parle de formation
professionnelle on parle de formation
professionnelle tout au long de la vie
et on parle aussi de formations en
alternance apprentissage et contrats de
professionnalisation
déjà quand on a dit ça on a créé de la
complication parce que au niveau de la
bourgogne et de la franche comté
actuellement les entreprises qui veulent
accéder et que l'on doit accompagner
dans cette formation professionnelle n'y
voit plus clair
c'est très compliqué les dispositifs
sont multiples et nombre je vais donner
un exemple juste ans il veut juste un
exemple une entreprise qui obtient
l'entreprise de câblage électrique
un exemple que je viens de vivre très
récemment une entreprise de câblage
électrique qui obtient à un nouveau
marché et qui a besoin que l'on forme et
c'est bien notre travail à la région
vous en conviendrez qui a besoin que
l'on forme ses salariés à cette 1/2
finaliste en passant par les sous
traitants et bien cette entreprise a mis
trois mois pour décoder les dispositifs
de la région bourgogne et pour y accéder
parce que il y a
près de cinquante disposition l'ordre
aux obligations dont une semaine
compliquée est ce que la formation
pardonnez moi est ce que la formation
professionnelle c'est compliqué oui
c'est compliqué c'est que bien sûr et
des années c'est pas une nouveauté vous
en compte la fonte des régions non c'est
pas la faute des régions parce que tout
le monde s'occupe de formation
professionnelle et de ce point de vue la
loi notre va conforter le rôle
d'organisateur de la formation
hellénique de proximité et ça c'est bien
la région est confirmé dans cette dans
cette vocation la formation
professionnelle madame je vous ai pas
couper le je pense que sûr il ya des
dispositifs qui sont extrêmement
intéressant aujourd'hui le dispositif
qui était mis en place pour le coup en
bourgogne en bourgogne est très
intéressant car peco l'idée étant de
travailler avec le monde économique le
monde de la formation sur les bassins
d'emploi pour mettre en place une vraie
stratégie de formation qui correspondent
à l'aigre à l'évolution des métiers sur
ce bassin d'emploi donc plus de
territorialisation de nos politiques
publiques je suis entièrement d'accord
avec ça et le deuxième sujet et je suis
d'accord avec vous sur le sujet et oui
mais c'est françois patriat qui a mis en
place qu'à picot voilà
mais je trouve que c'est un très bon
dispositif au territorialisée nous nos
politiques publiques parce que les
réalités de l'emploi et de la formation
et des besoins ce qui le désiraient
point c'est le deuxième point c'est il
faut être agile en matière de formation
professionnelle vous venez donner un
exemple d'une entreprise qui a mis trois
mois pour décoder un dossier moi je vous
donne un autre exemple
hermès qui s'est installée dans le nord
franche comté sa salle et pourquoi parce
que on a réussi à mettre en place un
appareil de formation extrêmement
compétitif au final c'est 500 emplois
qui sont créés sur le site grâce à
l'école millar que la région a largement
eu booster avec le 10 et 18 c'est donc
on a mis en place un dispositif à
d'autres qui correspond parfaitement
bien aux besoins d'une entreprise comme
celle là donc vous voyez il ya des
difficultés il ya aussi de l'agilité je
pense qu'il faudra encore plus de gilly
tels étaient les acquis via les tpe
n'ont pas accès à ces dispositifs de
choc aussi bonnes pratiques et agilité
ce sera donc
des mots de conclusion quand même voilà
il reste 4 minutes 30 danse dans cette
émission chaque donc invité sur ce
plateau a maintenant 30 secondes pour
conclure le tirage au sort a eu lieu
avant à l'émission et maintenant c'est
le tour dalat ailleurs pour conclure 30
secondes et après le couperet tombe
juste un mot c'est vraiment court comme
l'émission et traiter des sujets comme
le développement économique
d'abord notre région possède de
formidables atouts
ça c'est un fait indéniable encore
faut-il les mettre en valeur
encore faut-il aussi autre chose c'est
c'est combat que les logiques
européennes nationales de l'état qui
depuis trente ans ont conduit dans ce
pays et qui montre aujourd'hui leur
échec patent
au quotidien vous voit l'échec de ses
politiques
donc le 6 décembre les et les électeurs
auront le choix le choix de lannion
assez logique qui ont échoué
le choix d'élire des femmes et des
hommes autour de nathalie vermorel faut
conduire une autre politique une
politique alternative pour conduire une
politique d'avenir pour la région
bourgogne et la région franche comté
merci à marc laroche et écoutez moi je
m'adresse aux travailleurs et je tiens à
leur dire que dans ces élections n'y a
absolument rien de local
c'est visible que tous les programmes
dans qui nous ont été proposés dans
cette émission vise encore une fois à
soutenir la bourgeoisie ça fait des
années que cette politique elle est
menée donc je m'adresse à tous ceux
parmi les travailleurs qui ont la
conviction que ces gens qu'ils soient de
droite de gauche qu'ils aient été au
gouvernement ou qui rêvent d'y aller ils
n'auront aucune mesure favorable aux
classes populaires pour leur dire qu'il
faut qu'ils votent pour leur camp pour
leur classe pour leurs intérêts laurent
croizier pour le mode et à merci madame
donc en 2020 nous serons trois millions
de litres en bourgogne franche comté et
en votant pour la liste menée par
christophe grudler nous avons trois
millions de raisons de se battre pour
les emplois 3 millions de raisons
d'exiger un avenir pour nos enfants ici
la liste d'union du centre elle est
composée de femmes et d'hommes installés
dans la vie professionnelle et qui
seront conseillers régionaux à plein
temps et pas des cumulards de la vie
politique
la crise nous la vivons au quotidien et
nous la lisons pas dans libération ou
dans le figaro alors nous souhaitons une
alternance en bourgogne franche comté
oui mais pas une alternance com propose
so valais une alternance qui incarne un
changement une rupture dans les
pratiques politiques
merci denis sommaire moi je trouve que
la grande région qui arrive c'est un
sujet qui est absolument passionnante et
enthousiasmant on a des atouts
considérables pour la faire grandir
cette région
j'appelle nos concitoyens à se mobiliser
le 6 et le 13 décembre pour faire que
cette grande région réussi ce que nos
concitoyens aussi fassent attention les
extrêmes encourage toujours les extrêmes
et que nos concitoyens face à un choix
républicain
voyez je leur dis même pas voter
marie-guite dufay je leur dis qu'ils
fassent un choix républicain
merci denis sommaire julien cas bien
vous connaissez les dégâts de l'ump du
ps au niveau régional comme au niveau
national
l'herpès c'est la submersion migratoire
l'asphyxient fiscale la dette
le développement du communautarisme le
fondamentalisme islamique
la préférence étrangère donc la seule
alternative les 6 et 13 décembre
prochain c'est de voter la liste front
national de sophie montel et de faire
voter cette liste autour de vous merci
monsieur à car madame j'arrose est à
vous pour la liste et les rues délit
nous habitons une région pleine de
charme pleine de charme et il nous reste
à faire en sorte que notre région soit
attractive attractive d'un point de vue
économique attractive en matière de
création d'emplois et nous le ferons
avec un soutien financier ambitions à
l'innovation
et puis aussi avec ce travail de
proximité avec les départements
et puis je terminerais puisque nous
sommes à l'heure du déjeuner par une
citation que j'ai un peu arrangé mais
aussi 21e siècle président de brosses
premier président du parlement dijon qui
disait l'amour de la patrie vertus
dominante républicaine des grandes âmes
qui habite en bourgogne france-comté me
saisit toujours à l'aspect ou à la vue
d'une bouteille de bourgogne et dames
morceaux
t rajoutez un peu merci merci beaucoup
merci de comté mrc lilian merci mesdames
merci messieurs d'avoir participé à
cette émission
deux rendez vous donc mercredi à 22h45
et dimanche dès 20h15
bonne journée à tous au revoir